You know the situation.
You run your application locally in dev mode.
You hit refresh.
Your application works.
But then you push it to production,
and oh no.
What is going on?
In this video, we're going to take a
look at a pretty cool feature and use
case for ngrok that will help you get
rid of this situation,
or at least make debugging it a whole
lot simpler.
Let's have some fun.
Now,
even though I know that you know that
you have
100%
test coverage across unit tests, integration tests, acceptance
00:00:00: 00:00:00: integration tests,
00: unit tests,
00:  <i.e tests,
00: 00:  #1, you have a lot of your application
00: you have a lot of your application
00:  <strongly
00:
00:  <i.evaluations tests,
00:  <font-size tests,
00:  <i.e
00:  <unkown
tests,
smoke tests, chaos tests, performance and
synthetics.
00:00: 100%20:  #louisv
tests, smoke tests, canary tests, chaos tests, performance and